Adam you had a goal to make a feature
film before a certain age yeah tell us
about absolutely yeah so back in the day
I've been trying to be a filmmaker since
I was like 17 like in earnest
it's like this is what I'm gonna do but
I always thought it was gonna be like
Robert Rodriguez you know like he was my
idol
you know like young gun like doing this
feature by 23 I was like that's gonna be
me I definitely have that down then 23
came and 23 little Wyatt and I hadn't
done it I was like okay all right like
maybe maybe I'm not like Robert
Rodriguez maybe I'm more like I don't
Quentin Tarantino he did his bite like
27 his first feature I'll do that
27 comes 27 goes and I was I was sort of
devastated you know because I was
working on a lot of projects and doing a
lot of shorts but I hadn't gotten it
done it in and hit me when I turned 230
I was like that that's like a big
milestone when you turned 30
you know like you start thinking about a
lot of things you know like your body
starts changing you
you get like weird like you know like
aches in your knees or whatever like
just it just happens at 30
all right 40 yeah so I was like all
right I I have to do it you know like
I'm 30 I wanted to do it by at least 30
and I'm 30 like how do we do it before I
become 31 and I was going through you
know all of this at the beginning of the
year in January of I think it was 2015
and I was like okay I turned 31 in July
of 2015
how do I do a feature by that you know
and I had this idea it was like a very
small contained one room thing and I was
like okay I can do that like I can do
that quickly and so I just sort of set
my mind to it set a date and I was like
I have to do it you know like July was
that point where I was like I have to
with me shoot it by then so I just went
for it I'm January started writing the
script wrote the heck out of it you know
in February I started doing revisions to
the script well just going right into
pre-production it was the sort of thing
where I was like I don't have
time to look for funding and do that
whole like game cuz that's a whole
nother job that I just didn't have time
for so I was like all right I will find
a way to fund this it'll be super super
cheap I'll have to put a bunch on credit
cards through the old like Kevin Smith
clerks method and just pay for it that
way because I have to get it done and
you know I just started reaching out to
people compiling the cast and the crew
and like I found that you know there's a
certain point in projects where it does
sort of start moving like it's this big
boulder and you've been pushing it or
it's like this train on a track and
you've been pushing it and then the
train starts moving on its own and then
you realize like oh this this is
happening like people are into it people
like the project they want to be
involved like things doors start opening
for you strangely you know like the
universe helps you out a little bit and
that's what I found for that which was
amazing because I was like alright this
is supposed to happen so let's get it
done and then everything sort of worked
out and we found a great location and we
shot it in four days in June like a full
month before that before my birthday
before that got off day and and we did
it you know and looking back it's tough
to you know sort of pick apart exactly
like how it all came together but but it
did so I think the central driving thing
was that I had a date where I had to get
it done and I just found a way to make
it work
well let's backtrack a second because I
know you had this goal and you felt like
the clock was ticking but it wasn't like
you were just couchsurfing and going to
raves all the time you got a job you
were peeing before that and they don't
you had gone to college so you were
doing many other things that essentially
would tire a lot of people out sure yeah
absolutely I mean while I was doing that
I had this full-time job and it was that
thing where I think back when I was
trying to be like that broad with Robert
Rodriguez like 23 year old now that I'm
like far past that I go you know what I
actually
and ready and I would hate to have seen
what my twenty three-year-old feature
film would have been because I've seen
some of my twenty three-year-old short
films and I'm super embarrassed by them
you know what I mean so to try to put
that all together in a feature I don't
think mentally I was ready yet and I
don't think that from like getting your
ten thousand hours in in terms of like
the reps and in terms of writing and
directing like getting all those hours
in so you can actually make something
that I would think to be worthwhile for
myself I hadn't done that yet I hadn't
gotten the reps in you know so I needed
to just keep writing and and failing and
making shorts and having them not turn
out well and making pilots for web
series that never went anywhere and just
making all this stuff because in the
making stuff and in the writing stuff
and in the failing and in all those
rejections that's you know where you
really learn how to make a story and
craft a story and so I think by the time
I turned 30 I had done enough where I
was I was ready to do a feature you know
I knew that I could do it
I had done some you know fairly decently
larger scale shorts and I'm like you
know what I can do I can do a feature
too looking back do you think that
they're like two schools of filmmakers
there's two schools of filmmakers
there's one that's sort of this Rockstar
type they can just take these risks and
luckily everything turns out but then
there's others that plan things more and
maybe that's just their style and it
doesn't mean they're any less of a
filmmaker but they feel better knowing
that eyes are dotted T's are crossed
sure I mean there's there's definitely
part of that I think I think a lot of it
can be like some people are just sort of
little those like young savants you know
and some people are sort of right for
their time
you know like Whittle mariachi you know
have was it made in 2019 would anybody
care you know what I mean versus when it
was made in 92 93 when the indie
landscape was so different you know and
that's something to think about too like
there's a lot of like luck in the time
and luck in the place but in terms of
like you know people who are you know
potentially more pragmatic or like to
dot the i's and cross the t's and versus
the more rock stars I mean part of that
is probably you know just who you are as
a person and what you're gifted with and
I thought that I was a gifted young
auteur and I realized that I was not I
realized that I needed to really put in
the work and you know build up that
confidence build up you know the ability
to tell a story like and that's when I
sort of appreciated the stories about
you know like like JC Shandor you know
it was like 37 when he got his first you
know big film you know and he had been
working for a while he thought he was
gonna quit and that's like and it worked
out for him because he just kept going
and those are the stories that I really
you know are that I'm drawn to now and
those are the stories that I feel are
very under reported you know by
Hollywood because everybody likes the 23
year old you know who does something
splashy and big and it's like you know
kid you have not lived long enough to
really understand how to tell like a
story you know and there's some people
I'm sure that have but a lot of times
you know they're just riffing off of
movies and because that's all the
experience that they had I know that
that's the case for me is like I didn't
have enough of like life experience I
was just like oh I like Tarantino's
movie so I'm gonna make a version of
that you know and it's all about like
trying to find your own identity in that
regard but for me I needed you know to
just take the time and just work a lot
and fail a lot in order to get to a spot
you know where I can make that first
feature maybe not everybody's meant for
the lifestyle of what didn't Rodriguez
do like this medical testing and these
different things to raise money I mean
that and that's very like whoa when you
hear the story that's but again not
everybody and maybe I shouldn't have
used the word Rockstar because then that
but that's sort of like carefree
rebellious and some
other people might be more planners yeah
and it doesn't mean they're any less
talented it's just it's a sexier sell
when right yeah I put everything on a
credit card
yeah and luckily it worked out don't try
this at home kids but you know yeah and
that's the thing the interesting thing
you know like when you hear about like
the real stories behind it you'd figure
out like oh well Rodriguez even though
he was 23 he had been doing this for so
long and he had made hundreds of short
films by the time he made his feature at
23 and I had certainly not you know so
it's a little bit unfair to judge in
that regard because like what took me
ten years you know it took him ten years
but he was starting you know when he was
like 10 or 11 or whatever I was able to
get all those films in you know so he
was ready by the time you know he hit 23
obviously and also too so people are
just risk takers yeah i nature mm-hmm do
you think you're a risk taker or you're
more of a planner that's a good question
I I think I'm kind of both I like to
plan and I like to you know make sure
that everything's sort of ready but like
you do have to take risks a lot you know
you want to sort of have the universe
try to show you the way a little bit but
if it doesn't you still have to have the
courage to make you know that leap take
that risk
you